foreign
are you considering designing now
yeah
you guys are pushing really yeah
not right now nope okay
Joy Reid look at you I see you there Joy
George what's going on here hey George
did you
in your bank account
[Music]
back up
let him through
look if you guys don't behave there's no
way you're gonna get information back to
the to the people so if you make way and
act like you know civilized people I
know you all are I know a lot of You by
first name we talk all the time let's
get to the podium make some space and
then we'll address can you all agree
make some snakes make space there you go
look at that guy I'll address you guys
but let's head to the podium all right
go go go come on come on let's move over
hello
how are you Wednesdays
watch out
my questions
what about the bad check in Lancaster
Pennsylvania right there podium's right
there all right all right there's a
Podium right here look at all these mics
you're in front of me
all right
we made it here all right so I know you
all have questions
I know you all have questions I know
that everybody's been waiting for the
moment for me to come out and talk to
you guys
look this is the beginning of the
ability for me to address it down and
defend myself we have an indictment we
have all we have the information that
the government wants to come after me on
and I'm going to comply I've been
confined throughout this entire process
I have no desire not to comply at this
point they've been gracious in there now
I'm gonna have to go and fight to defend
myself the reality is is sorry it's a
witch hut because
it makes no sense that in four months
four months five months I'm indicted you
have Joe Biden's entire family receiving
deposits from nine nine family members
receiving money from forest from foreign
destinations into their bank accounts
it's been years of exposing a lot of you
here have reported on them and yet no
investigation is launched into them I'm
gonna fight well and I'm just going I'm
getting back there I'm gonna fight my
battle I'm gonna deliver I'm gonna fight
the witch said I'm gonna take care of
clearing my name and I look forward to
doing that
hold on hold on hold on
what do you say to that I would like
some of you guys have some questions in
an orderly fashion and we'll start right
now why would you apply for unemployment
benefits When you had a job making 120
000 a year Rachel this is
accurate information and I will get to
clear my name on this during the
pandemic it wasn't very clear I don't
understand where the government's
getting their information but I will
present my prosecutors
say that you got over twenty thousand
dollars in unemployment benefit sir how
is that acceptable ma'am like I said my
employment was changed during the time I
don't understand where the government's
coming from miles
[Music]
I I have plenty of evidence that we will
now be sharing with the government in
this case
no I did not
re-election that's not up for me to know
elections are very tricky and it's up to
the people I trust them to decide what's
best friends
what do you think will make people
by the work I do body and I
think Mr Santos are you headed to
Washington now yes I am I have to go
back and vote tomorrow we have uh one of
those consequential votes in in this
Congress which is a border Bill and I'm
very looking forward to being there to
vote
right now well I'm not going to address
just the speaker I'll address leadership
I appreciate everybody's patience with
with my presence in Congress as you know
the media has it's it's you know ways of
doing things and I respect you guys I've
maintained good report with a lot of you
guys I've spoken with a lot of you guys
and I have the intention to continuing
that Open Door some of you who are from
the hill know how to find me some of you
here from the district don't have a hard
time finding me it's about keeping in
line of communication so I appreciate
leadership for being patient at this
time and for allowing the process to
play out I think this is about innocent
until proven guilty this starts I have
my right to fight to prove my innocence
as the government has the right to fight
to try to find me guilty in whatever
still now
you're being accused for a loan well
because the media is not Journey or the
judge so I will present that to the
jurors and to the judge in this
courthouse and to the
well if Congress requested together
you won't uh negotiate a plea I'm
feeling look it's hard
I'm addressing one of your colleagues
yeah I don't want to give the backup so
as usual security I I do my best to be a
positive person life is already as bad
as it gets it slips I'm moving so I I'm
fine
[Music]
the way I look at it I'll be a chairman
of a committee in a couple of years
look at the Senate
well it's the ledge right so are you
working are you are you gonna allow the
process to play itself
how did you first learn about the
charges against you and also can you
talk about the process of surrendering
did they arrest you no it was very it
was very amicable very peaceful these
guys did a phenomenal job we clearly
came right under your noses and you
didn't see us come in today uh and now
we're leaving obviously we're addressing
you guys had all the intention of the
world to be out here with you guys I'm
gonna keep fighting I'm gonna keep
fighting for what I believe and I'm
going to keep fighting to represent my
district I'm going to keep fighting to
deliver results and now I have to keep
fighting to deliver you know to defend
my innocence and I'm gonna do that
[Music]
Governor holkle is entitled to her
opinion I don't represent her she is not
my constituent so I saw
I saw your Facebook report today
you look pretty stressed
when I saw you sit down and The Judge
first time speaking what was going
through your mind what are you feeling
well when it's your first time in
experiencing something of this nature
this nature I I quite frankly don't
believe I was stressed I did the best I
could to just keep my composure I was I
was fine
um but again this is this has been an
experience you know for a book or
something like that
I appreciate you guys I appreciate you
guys here's what we'll do because
guys guys
I will you see that is information
you'll never get because that is the
media's your intention is to go harass
them and make their life miserable
you're not getting there
George where's your husband
you don't
[Music]
know
thank you Jimmy I'll take the flag thank
you ma'am
thank you